and man this is November 4  I had this idea of creating a zero g  sequence for some time  Tom said yeah we're going to for real  we're going to get on a real plane we're  going to crash it and I thought this is  that we're going to have  there is a real physical challenge into  it 0g it was really developed for the  Apollo missions we inject the aircraft  into an orbit you are in three four you  are weightless  it's a real sense built inside of real  planes that's actually ready going to go  25,000 foot up and go zero gravity and  we had to prepare as best we could but  then we don't quite know exactly what's  going to happen  wanted to be wild and violent and  spontaneous for an audience they're just  seeing it's happening in real time  there's no edit it's they're good  [Music]  experience this historic stunt in  virtual reality at the Austin Convention  Center ballroom be  you